and welcome back everybody the state of
chess comm quarter 1 of the year 2020
can we just give 2020 back anybody else
into that can we just like send it back
and skip I might be into that um
the year 2020 rolls on whether we like
it or not and the quarter one coverage
continues here addressing not just some
some of the stuff we always do on the
show give you some updates talk about
product we do usually get into at least
one or two sensitive topics facing our
community in that particular time at
that particular time in that particular
quarter but this this episode if you're
just tuning in got into some very
sensitive stuff talking about cheating
what we're doing about it as it relates
to a number of different things there's
a reason we kind of stacked the show the
way we did talking about the premium
marina opportunities we're applying and
or providing everyone is a new premium
perk and the questions and worries that
have come in about cheating and how it
relates to that we're gonna get into
some of it some of you asked it in chat
I've got them right here the title
player community and their worries about
it as games increase online and then of
course just what were what we do in
general and and our talk about that will
will be will be shared on on our
different digital media platforms that's
a fancy word for things like YouTube and
twitch and Facebook you can see it later
if you just tuned in or just watch the
video on demand on Twitch if you are
already a subscriber there so on that
note it's time to break into the more
the questions that were surrounded or
relating directly to this Fair Play talk
and some of them will open up doors of
us talking a little more about the
technical stuff as much as we can and
and without any further ado let's do it
so thank you to all that have been
asking interesting and intriguing and
hard-hitting challenging questions so
Fair Play questions from sizzle biscuits
says what sort of appeal process will be
in place for people who are flagged for
cheating so the the appeal progress we
already have in place will be the same
process in place so when you say will be
it's already in place and that is that
every single account close has the right
to appeal by emailing in to support
title players are actually contacted
directly with their closures so they are
actually given a private opportunity
before even the public knows about it
given their position and
they're their accomplishments and often
their influence in the chess community
and the fact that they do a lot of good
despite maybe this one mistake we give
them that opportunity but everyone can
send in an email you can live and give
the most detailed appeal you want
explain things in the most rarest of
cases appeals have led to improvements
to not just our algorithm but our
process sometimes it wasn't the
algorithms fault but somebody who was on
our team who was maybe new and misread
something right sometimes it has led to
a massive breakthrough in terms of how
we evaluated something that the the
algorithm or the engines were telling us
so we encourage anyone who thinks they
were cheated wrongly to appeal also know
that a lot of peels to get declined the
first response is then to give us a
explicit of proverbial middle you know
what and then often after a couple
months later they come back and say you
know what you were right I was angry I'm
sorry we've had some really interesting
cases people saying things like I don't
cheat on my wife I don't cheat on my
taxes and I certainly don't cheat at
chess that person admitted to cheating a
few months later and so maybe he needs
to have some tougher discussions in his
life okay we move on Ross was asks can I
ask about sandbagging I'm really glad
you brought this up not just sandbagging
in terms of the accounts but a lot of
people are commenting right now I saw
Gotham chefs I'm not sure if it was
relating to premium arenas I have
another question coming up by let's see
member GTG Pro 2018 wants to talk about
how sandbagging will be determined in
premium arenas so we're already doing
that all the time and obviously it's not
the most common form you think of
cheating usually its engine cheating in
terms of the masses that we close but we
do also close people for sandbagging it
happens sometimes friend on friend
action where they try to sandbag with
each other it does happen sometimes for
non cash prizes but you know our members
are holding events all the time you guys
are an awesome community you're holding
your own Club championships your only
daily chess events your old live chess
club championships and we try to empower
you to do that and sometimes people
cheat in your event for no reason they
just did right and you're upset about it
or your or your community members are in
your club and we get reports about that
and we act on it right I would say the
amount of auto-detection zhh we have for
sandbagging is obviously less because
the much greater part of our investment
goes into the statistical measurements
and you know
the thresholds and algorithms that were
trying to establish with catching the
most sophisticated forms of cheating
frankly the more important ones but we
do act on sandbagging and I'll say this
if anyone is caught having sandbag over
this last month anybody put it this way
if you win a prize in a premium arena
you can know that you are gonna be under
massive scrutiny and no one will
actually get that cash out prize until
we have reviewed their games in great
detail not just the history of their
account but everything about them so if
you plan on winning a cash prize and
you're not a clean playing premium
member a good standing member of our
community you're probably not going to
get that cash prize and instead you'll
probably just expose yourself to some
things that you were doing in a shady
way so to answer your question think
about it this way not only can I make
this promise to you people have asked
that of course I can make this promise
because we're not gonna start paying
people cash who are gaming you and us so
there's only a few cash prizes each week
don't game the system cuz you're gonna
be caught let alone even if you come
close to winning we'll probably catch
you so yeah of course we are for the
premium arena how do you plan to prevent
people okay this is the same sort of
thing we're already monitoring it we're
monitoring the fact that once people
play in this premium arena we will be
doing a check of what their rating has
been for the last month so if someone
has gone from 1,600 to 1,100 in the last
month maybe we don't know what about
right now you're right but we're gonna
know what he plays in the premium arena
and that might not be something that
allows him to win a prize he or she
justshe detection happen for all rated
games from chess society someone asks a
similar question which is do we actually
check all let's say 5 million games
played versus human beings every day I
would say we don't necessarily check the
verse computer games because by
definition it's versus a computer but
and if you decide you want to do that
you're kind of cheating yourself it's
there for your training
but do we check all 5 million games
every day within the best of our ability
I can say that that's one of the major
investments of the tech right the tech
is about you know it takes t1 analysis
that everyone's you know self couldn't
proclaim cheat experts are doing on
reddit and everywhere else some of them
are very good I'm not trying to make fun
but you know what it takes I would argue
our algorithm goes way beyond that
that's where a lot of the investment
goes but also the investment goes into
how do we improve and catch people that
are blatantly cheating
faster quicker better stronger we're
doing that all the time we are I mean I
guess our monthly reports say how many
games were reviewing in a month so let's
see if we review 94 million in March for
for fair play clearly ok what's 5
million times 30 that's a hundred and
fifty million if I'm doing my math right
so clearly we did not review every game
I cannot claim that but we are reviewing
a lot of them and then we continue to
review games especially as they relate
to tournaments and sensitive events all
the time so that's that's the best way I
can answer that for pants says the cheat
detection system do we contact other
websites because some of my opponents
have used other websites at the same
time I I can't say exactly how well we
can track because that would be
revealing some of the cool stuff we can
do under the hood we can track very much
what's going on on other sites and
whether someone is using other sites at
any time with a separate device or mid
game on the same device whatever we can
do we can do that and we do do that we
do not share what our our algorithm does
with it is not like an open source
collaboration we've talked about it a
lot III don't know that ultimately
that's not in chest outcomes future I
can tell you that both Eric and I that
the current leadership if if we are
through the leaders at chess calm in
five years we hope to be that may be
something that we consider to make more
and more out there I'll say this the
reason we don't is not just for like you
know protecting our investment that
we're doing with chest coms specific
events we do have to make sure our
algorithm is as awesome as it can be for
our events we can't always worry about
every other site as much as we'd like to
but also right now you know we are not
operating in the perfect realm that I
would feel comfortable being more public
about it because I don't want cheaters
to know the very very few areas that
make it harder for us right and so
that's that's why we don't do that as
far as sharing it openly it's it's more
and maybe someday maybe someday we will
you know we want to make sure everyone
has safe chess as they say we have safe
chess coming your way that's our goal
was I allowed to make that joke maybe
that we're gonna continue okay yo cool
says does chess come legit report every
single game so we talked about that as
far as the amount of games I showed you
we went over 94 million in March not all
150 million roughly
but pretty pretty good Bradley bloom
says wants to know changes in sheet
detection will change the number of
title players cut you're darn right it
is and it's unfortunate how do you know
that cheating was getting worse even
given the cheat detection method was
that cheating was getting worse given
that that's a fair point
I wasn't I'll put it this way we're
offering more opportunities and reasons
of motivation to cheat because we're
investing more more people are playing
chess online than ever so I guess by the
sheer numbers and some of the sensitive
stuff I've gone through this week
frankly having conversations with people
that wouldn't normally cheat that's why
I said I acknowledge you guys I was
pretty nervous to talk about this like
it's upsetting it is it's very it's it's
literally the most difficult part of my
job and I think often and daily about
how I could get somebody else to do this
and then ultimately it comes around to
you know kind of a sensitive nature of
it how much we care and how personally
we want to give people time that and a
lot of people do do I don't even handle
them but I mean our cheat detection team
does so much more work than I do and
people do handle a lot of sense of
conversations but in terms of some of
the big ones that I've had or big
closures we've had to make it's not the
fun part of my job and I don't know that
it's getting worse I just had more of
those conversations and the fact that
we've made some breakthroughs you're
right you're right it's it's it's
something that has us acting very
strongly on and being too upset and
that's why we're being more unspoken
because we do want to change the culture
I'm unhappy with the culture as it
exists and we don't want people to think
that cheating is is something that they
can do and get away with even for a
little bit let alone you know for a
while and so maybe our algorithm
breakthroughs are just something
exposing a light that's already been
there either way the light is being
exposed
so let's hopefully change that behavior
Brant Brandon Atterbury asks as we move
into more official rate of play
occurring online are we gana going to
get USCF online ratings integrated on
profiles that is a great feature request
I can tell you we're already working on
it with feed a ratings in terms of our
player you ever been to chess calm /
what is it just talk calm / players or
something can we go there real quick
let's go to the full screen mode
doot-doot-doot I don't even know where
at top layers there it is top players
you know we already have profiles that
link to everything that is their chests
calm everything profile but also we're
integrating ways that people's standard
profile will also be able to be
integrated with their feed a rating and
and be up to date so it's not just
someone comes on and says hey I'm twenty
nine hundred feet a bro right and we
know they're lying it'll be a so working
on that and why not do it with us CF so
a great question Brandon editor Barry I
will add that to Eric's favorite list
it's called the feature list for twenty
twenty seven when he gives me everything
I want that he never tells me know
anymore he says Danny y'all do that
20:27 I hope you're it's right now I
speak for the people Eric you will give
us what we want okay let's see okay this
is a good question I'm glad we already
shared the full screen we'll be going
back to it Max & Lily Nick I know you
you're a model bar as we love you ma'am
can I save OTB classical games on chess
come to make a personal database yes you
can and I'll show you and this tool is
getting better and better
but I'll show you what you can currently
do and when a live 960 game occurs what
Barre and what variant statistics will
be available so that's a very good
question
offering game report statistics for any
sort of chess variant is like is on that
twenty twenty seven roadmap it'll come
sooner than that but we're still trying
to make our awesomeness of what key
moments can we give you how can we help
you get better with great insights into
your games with the game report right
now we've got so much attention there
it's hard for me to also say how can I
make someone a better bughouse player or
chess960 or anything else
obviously on that list chess960 comes
first it's the first variant but it's
just it's not something we're doing in
this exact moment let me talk about how
you can actually save games over the
board so let's sound let's go to
fullscreen here look at that guy talking
on the homepage we'll get away from that
guy
okay the chess calm analysis let's go
let's go to an article so let's see
we'll grab did you know you can grab the
PGN and analysis for any article you
just hit this little share button it's
kind of small
but it brings up anything you could ever
want we'll grab the PGN so here's the
deal the same way you can enter what I'm
about to do
just copy a PGN and click load you can
also do the same for any manual game
right when you're done with an analysis
you can make any kind of new analysis
and you can enter move yourself right so
you can do enter your entering games
from your over the board event right
you're making comments and saying like
you know I should have not played that
whatever right you're done and when
you're done with anything you're either
manually entering copying from somewhere
you could also convert any game you've
already played into this you can save it
and a lot of people don't know you
already have the ability after saving it
to see every saved analysis you've ever
done so if you looking for a list of
your you know whatever what are we gonna
call your collection your library of
things we already have that and there's
actually some analyses here that I've
actually done for videos that I did
because I use chess comms analysis too
let's see if I can find one you can see
these are videos I've done like for our
YouTube channel what's one with some
okay so here's one where I I analyze
this these are all my comments so this
is a saved game Danny's game in fact if
I copy this link I can actually share
this game instantly with every member of
the world either on social media or the
global chess community guess what I just
did I just gave everybody my private
analysis on chess TV right there and you
can click that link and go there right
so a lot of people don't know that there
are other sites that have similar
features to this right a lot of people
don't obviously it's not called the same
we know V chess has Studies chest will
has some great stuff I know that all
kinds of great chess space is really the
original you know organization and
database software that a lot of people
use so if you don't have chess base for
my money it's still the best I may be
not supposed to say that but it's the
truth chess base is awesome but I can
make any analysis I want I can do
whatever I want I can make any comments
I want I can then save that analysis and
then always have it in my saved analysis
folder and we're only gonna continue to
work on this and make it even more
awesome for you so if you didn't know
that you can hear something that's cool
look at this I can go to my archive
where's my archive oh yeah it's under
played okay I go to my archive let's see
I played a horrible game disco I
actually was more accurate than this guy
it does my game report here I click game
report so I've got this game report I
got my own analysis I want to analyze
like Bishop c4
dumb like like Danny like Danny you're
dumb Danny you are dumb bro right and
then I click update' right once I update
I'm saving that analysis guess where
it's saved now do I not only have a link
but if I if it's saved you know and I
can do whatever else I want right make
new variations and whenever I update and
save it it'll be in my saved analysis
right there at the top guess what I can
also do to that I can edit the analysis
and say state of chess comm cheating
show where I said things I might regret
later
boom daddy why am i typing okay there
you go
click enter okay and I can save anything
I want for a future analysis session so
alright we'll get out of this now but
again maybe you didn't know that and if
you didn't now you know that you can use
chess economic analysis save anything
you're doing do anything you want you
can share that with anybody if you want
nobody can access your saved analysis
that's private that's like your own
little area right but if you ever want
to share it you can and there you go
hopeful hopeful you like that so um okay
Devon 771 for says will there be an FM
not I am speechless champion we have
gotten a lot of requests from national
masters feed a master does do the same
thing I don't know that's what that's
something we're gonna do not because it
doesn't sound awesome and maybe we will
do it as like maybe a commuter slightly
a community rain event maybe you know
chess club could provide a price but
it's not about the money necessarily
it's just that the I'm not a GM thing
has actually actually been something
that was requested secretly for years it
also is a secret excuse to let me lose
in front of thousands of people people
love that right and I think that a lot
of those im's are also kind of known as
chess personalities and it's not to say
that some of the FM's and NMS aren't
known as like more chess commentators or
whatever but the I'm not a GM speeches
champion was a little bit of kind of
meant to be like failed GM's who like
gonna be so like to like to self
deprecated make fun of Laurence Trent
all that stuff right everyone loves
doing that so that's what that was about
and a lot of those players are kind of
known as faces of commentary so it's not
something we always thought of doing as
like a regular event for other levels
not I don't know yet maybe
right maybe we might even do a pots or
speech Chess Championship if you're a
Potts or raise your hand I'm a bot sir
can i play right maybe we'll do
something like that who knows we always
have lots of fun doing stuff with you
guys so but there are no plans yet chess
guy wants to know will there be more
classical time controls events on chest
outcome for those of you who don't know
about the Sun way sick yes can we just
take a moment to appreciate that
the the Sun way sit kiss which I'm gonna
pull up real quick and our news dear kid
didn't do did you do here it is the Sun
way sickness was the first ever online
classical event everyone was proctored
I'm gonna be totally honest with you cuz
tidal players always want to know and
that's the whole I was saying be totally
honest with you why do I even say that
I'm always honest and I shouldn't be
saying that and the problem is that you
know I'm saying too much but I'm gonna
tell you there were some Fairplay
violations in this event so you can know
you were protected and we closed them
but also we also went through all the
measurements and protocols then I
promise we do during this event our team
worked super hard shout out to Simon who
has literally been putting in extra
hours to heap will keep our community
happy this event had everyone on zoom'
he was the first-ever classical event
held with like prizes and things that
matter it was kind of it was kind of
groundbreaking it wasn't feat a
classical rated feat a wouldn't you know
go for that at this point in time I
don't think it wasn't you was it but it
was a classical event on chest comm and
it was kind of a big deal and it's still
going I think I think um anyway so
that's that
Chesson black and white when will there
be lessons aimed at 1800 or 2002 players
great question we are working on it I
would argue there already are some video
series that have been converted to
lessons so chess in black and white I'm
not sure you really know that but I mean
let me show you real quick in our in our
full feature again let me just show you
our videos for example right here I just
clicked on I clicked on Anatoly Karpov
top 5 movies like this is a video series
ok did you know that right on the right
here it says it says try the lesson any
videos you now watch on chess comm you
can try a lesson and this this is you is
instantly a lesson start the challenges
this is a lesson geared at you
I don't even know that I could find the
movie er one of five what's your car
puff wooden genius move to carp off
later prevent black from contesting
control the a file he played this move I
remember this game Oh si you're a local
Sasha welcome back how should white
prepare to double rooks on the a file
clearly its Bishop c2 so this is a
lesson with videos by Simon Williams
with with lessons so chess and black and
white there are lessons that are geared
toward you and you should use them and
enjoy them okay Josh rod any plans for
another component Komodo versus human
event in fact it's already in the works
we just had Komodo versus David smeared
on Komodo versus Alex Lenderman is
coming in May I'm just gonna answer it
that weeks we got a lot of questions
here I already answered that
any plans for title Tuesday to be ten
rounds again or even more than that yes
[Music]
there are changes coming to the title
Tuesday format to again bigger prizes
maybe more rounds maybe something we
learned from the Abu Dhabi blitz
championship which was ten thousand
dollars and for a single day event the
most we ever had in terms of the final
stages being a knockout I'm not gonna
say more about that but we are working
on things for the title Tuesday it
should make even even those who are
still very critical of our fair play you
know despite my whole message today not
to say that my message should matter but
you know we did give you a lot talk to
you about our philosophy in terms of
losing so many PR battles to some of you
who think you know we're not acting fast
enough but winning the war and
continuing to invest and make sure we do
catch cheaters so we're not gonna stop
and we think the title Tuesday with some
format changes might be even better for
some of you that are still critics of
fair play and what chest outcome does to
catch cheaters so look for that coming
soon
chest TV our engines allowed to be used
for personal friend to friend games from
Michaela G M a CA ulj they are not now I
will say this we have had this happen
and in cases where both friends wrote in
and both friends appealed and said we
were aware of this we have dealt with
them cooperatively to not consider it be
cheating but sometimes this excuse is
made and it's not totally honest and
even if that's the case
it's not something that is necessarily
approved we have talked a lot about
creating our own sort of pool of players
who want to do that it's actually called
centaur chess if you didn't know it's
actually a thing and there are some
people who are very good at Centaur
chest there are sent to our chest world
champions people who play openly me and
my favorite engine versus you and your
favorite engine it leads to some
fascinating chess I gotta be honest I'm
a fan like the computer Chess
Championship he's a brilliant Leela
games we're seeing versus stockfish
check out my videos on YouTube shameless
plug um some of the computer games if
you dismiss that they draw 75 in a row
they come up with brilliant wins like
that Bishop bending right that are just
like blow all of us away but sent to our
chests is also a thing it is not
something we currently openly endorsed
on chess comm we're working on it
Eric has it on his feature list for 2027
just kidding it'll be sooner Steffi 9/4
wants to know what's happening with the
protest League finale it has been moved
to September because of copán 19 the
organizers and sponsors that we have
there worked with us so that we didn't
have to kind of completely cancel it
depending on where the world goes maybe
it would have actually been possible the
end of May I don't know what's gonna
happen with Koba 19 like all of you and
I think it might just depend on the
region you're in people might start
making more individual decisions on that
but we moved it to September anyway and
that is when the protest League finals
will happen live in Oslo you should be
there it's going to be an amazing chess
eSports finale the BIA muth wants to ask
assuming that you have been putting the
time to actually improve in chess and
thus increase your rating from 12 to
1500 in the span of 12 months will your
cheatin algorithm taken to effective the
player could have actually improved his
games so that's a very good question
because it leads to one of the most
common misconceptions and you're gonna
love this answer be a myth anyone who
cares about our cheat detection this is
gonna give you more insight art-sheet
detection is result and rating blind in
that and this this will be frustrating
for people who think of it old-school
but then ultimately hopefully
illuminating and encouraging because
this is why I can claim we don't ever
act in a mount mob mentality
I hate when pee
come to me and say this person can't be
this good you don't know you don't know
who the next magnus carlsen is people
say like this person can't improve that
or this person could never find that
tactic people pay brilliant chess games
all the time plus how is it that you
could hold it against somebody that by
definition of playing a great game they
did match up with an engine a few times
right it assumes that you believe we're
placing labels on people and we're
saying this person can't win against
this guy this person's not capable of
that completely not what we do now when
it comes to manual review there are
results that catch your eye
and sure enough anybody is a human being
and if someone has an outstanding result
we wouldn't be doing our job to protect
and serve you if we didn't look into
that right so certainly results might be
a trigger point of why we look into you
but we would never and have never closed
in fact so many people that have tried
to trick us in their in their confession
emails you just don't know who I am I've
just gone from 12 to 1800 this month I'm
telling you all that stuff and this is a
show of being super direct so I'm
staying with the tone it's total BS and
we know it it doesn't matter because our
our algorithm is matching up the
blueprint of your game to what we have
measured and know is possible for human
beings to match up with engines in all
kinds of ways and I can't say exactly
there's so many different ways we do
that but it took puts together what we
call our cheat report and it takes it
takes top move up match up combined with
what am I allowed to say be careful
Danny I know Roland's watching it takes
top move analysis combined with
obviously activity of your device but
also it takes the murder weapon really
out of it it's device blind as well
because we know based on our investment
the fact that we have analyzed millions
and millions of games I would tell you
this we knew certain people were
cheating it over the board events long
before fee day or the USCF did and you
could say well why didn't you do
something about it well again remember
that's not really our jurisdiction right
and when asked privately we always
assist in help we want safe chess as I
said practice safe chess but but our job
is to the reason we have nine full-time
employees on salary right is because is
because their job is to constantly be
measuring inputting data pulling
information finding ways that we can see
patterns of irregular irregularity what
the IOC does it measures not just
whether someone has a high you know
white blood cell or oxygen count in
their blood but it also knows what their
normal level of blood is and that's the
best I can tell you in terms of what
we're doing all the time is investing
here for you and we are not making
subjective opinions and that's where we
have to act in a way that is a little
bit harder than everyone else who gets
to act and just say this person couldn't
do this or this person's outperforming
their rating even gm's it's often wrong
often people are wrong and that
sometimes people would be surprised that
people we closed for cheating because
their result was not as good as you
would think but maybe they maybe they're
not good at balancing the engine device
they're accessing maybe they get
themselves under time pressure and still
lose right our algorithm is measuring
what you're doing that it's not
appropriate in terms of assistance and
it is not it is not ever holding results
or your chest strength against you it's
one of the biggest illusions and again
that's one of things we feel good about
so you can trust we're not gonna hold it
against you if you have a great event
but if you had a great event cheated and
then try to tell us privately no you
just don't know how good I am
we're gonna see right through it because
it's not how we were measuring you
anyway it wasn't about your result it's
about the indications that your moves
gave us in terms of what we know is
humanly probable for people to do not
possible but probable right and that's
that that's the way we can act and the
best I can describe that as if if you
were in court and you said I just lifted
that thirteen hundred pound refrigerator
with one hand and it guys like no you
didn't and you're like yeah I did you
can't prove him wrong and he's like
we'll do it again
and you're like nope I can't prove you
wrong and I can't prove and you don't
have to prove that you can do it again
but guess which one of us wins in a
court of law in terms of the way our
current legal system works
it's the reason it's called beyond
reasonable doubt is because you're never
measuring the impossibility of things
but we do a great job of measuring the
improbability and we do it with
integrity because we're constantly
measuring the chances we might be wrong
okay
you're not doing statistics with
integrity unless you're also keeping
yourself in check so we're not just
screaming on I'm on a rooftop or crying
wolf when
we'll have great results if I put this
hand super close to the camera you might
say it's a hand you might say it looks
like a baby's butt you might say it
looks like a hamburger bun it's not
until the hand becomes clear that you
actually know what you're seeing in
statistics right you have to have enough
information to really understand and
measure with integrity and that's the
realm that we operate in and so the best
way to consider it is we're not trying
to make false accusations we're trying
to make accusations we can stand by
being conservative but also protecting
all of you and so without getting into
more things I've probably already said
too much that how our indicators are the
type of statistical methods we use some
of them are well-known some of them are
not some of them are a combination of
well-known stuff that people just
haven't other people don't do yet but
that's what we're doing and we're doing
it to measure the probability of
impossibility the probability of
impossibility never excludes the
possibility of an anomaly I sound like
neo me and I'm like the architect in the
matrix or something okay the probability
of a possibility never excludes the
probability that the possibility could
be an anomaly so there's always the
chance of an anomaly but there isn't the
chance that we went in court that we
would act on a meaning we would only do
it if we know what we're doing and we're
measuring is this a baby's butt is this
a hand is it not and as soon as we know
that's a baby's butt you can bet that we
put some powder on that baby this is
this this reference got way out of
control
moving on here we go please post the
open letter from Smith law fan we will
be sending the letter in chest comma
messages from yours truly it's already
written at McCauley J again the same guy
from Chester V says what is just calm
doing about those who are pushy and
making a movement under 10 seconds for
example in chess that are 30 to 60
minutes I have been having a ton of them
online I'm just a beginner so again
there's different all I can say is
there's different feelings on that some
people really feel that it's unfair to
start a game when we should be focused
and you're not moving some people want
you to be aborted in that process others
want time to think we're always trying
to hear the community and what they want
different time controls have different
restraints of how much leniency we give
you like if someone hasn't made a move
in bullet I think in like 30 seconds we
consider that half the time control and
the game should end right in longer
games you're given a lot more time in
see to think about your first move in
960 games you're given more time that's
our job we're working all the time I'm
sorry if it's not perfect we're doing
what we can to measure that um I would
say that if someone is complaining to
you and being rude diamond member McHale
Jay you should report them you know that
you can click on any profile and report
that person let's show everybody how you
do that let's show everybody how we
report somebody for abuse huh let's do
it huh
we going to live chess and I click on a
game
hold on loading right we've got gamax
and I'm like hey gamax I don't like your
way you're adding here I click on him
and I can click on more or even just the
button right there I can report anybody
I can report them for abuse for stealing
for cheat for stalling or not study not
stealing you're not stealing for
stalling
he stole my rating points by beating me
I can report for verbal abuse for for
anything right did you know that you can
do that again I'm gonna show you again
click on any user name and click the
report button and tell us what's
bothering you and we will do everything
we can to act so there you go that's
that full screen on to the next question
here efore beefs a whole bunch of
letters e for bc for queen h5 queen of 7
oh that's the form of check my cool
username do the monthly reviews consider
variance we do catch people for cheating
and variants people cheat lesson
variants the communities are smaller and
more loyal that's just just so you know
it's true so if you're a variant player
a little bit of badger pride for you
people cheat lesson variants 1 it's
harder to cheat in variants also there
aren't as many engines for it but also I
think the communities are smaller and
more tight-knit we do check for cheating
like for player chess as you said and
all I can say is yes we are but you know
that the closures are obviously gonna be
less extreme like that number I gave you
of 5 million live chess games played
every day
that doesn't include include 4 4 player
chess variants right I don't know how
many 4 plus 4 player chess variants
we've had over the last month and a half
in 2020 the the second World Team
Championship final four player chess
stream blah blah blah okay Bobo ok
featuring three title players in was won
by a team led by cunning Co for play
chess oh so this is just an
advertisement for player chess
apparently this guy has an agenda
apparently check out for player chess
calm I'll give him I'll give him his due
let me just show you
you go under play
and you can go to four player chess if
you didn't know I was very addicted to
four player chess for some time it's a
ton of fun it's awesome it's also a bit
a bit nutty and exhausting and my brain
hurts and so I stay away from it okay
hands hands pans live as a programmer
how can I apply for the Fairplay team
you can email email email I'm talking a
lot I need to take a breath it's been an
intense show you can email Fairplay at
chess calm I said it correctly we also
have chest comps last jobs if you're not
aware we're always hiring our companies
expanding we have more than 150
full-time employees now we provide
health care and dental we provide
bonuses all around the world to everyone
who works there we do everything we can
to help our team and our employees be
happy our company's doing what it can so
if you're interested in working for us
we're interested in considering you so
go ahead and apply at chest coms last
jobs how's that for a big chest
statement good job Dan BJ H says have
you considered adding international
variants such as shogi and Sean key to
chess comm I don't even know what those
are bjh I love you thank you for all the
work you've been doing here today no
kidding I know I know what yogi is no we
have not
I'll let Eric no that'll be added to the
list of 27 27 along with every other
variant that people want and everything
else that we want okay Danny wrench can
you please make more live streams of you
playing I like you streaming well I like
you amazing master thanks for the
request
nf chess one three is there a chest comm
desktop app for Windows on the roadmap
not currently I gotta be honest week we
have a very very small windows
development team that often gets pulled
into other areas the the Android and iOS
market share dominate the market and I
hate to sound like a businessman who has
to make sound decisions but I'm a
businessman who has to make sound
decisions along with Eric and the whole
team here and right now the market share
is just not big enough so if you have a
Windows Phone that's awesome but we just
don't have enough people using our site
we
those apps to justify it right now so
hopefully the webinar face is ok with
you or and I know I don't want to
encourage you to go iOS or Android
because I don't really care I love you
know but it's just it's not something
that we're doing right now and I'm sorry
at lonegan says I enjoy watching Daniel
H commentating on chest comm and wish
okay cool thank you
good humor in gay play that's just a
cool comment thank you that's lon again
appreciate that mine SS says well chest
comm make online titles like chest comm
Master that is a fantastic question one
that has been long considered debated
and ultimately sometimes when you don't
know what to do you do nothing which is
obviously why you can see we have not
done that yet there's a lot of different
opinions on that I will share some
general opinions we've gotten from a lot
of experts of other games and eSports
communities and you might really like
this so I'll tell you a lot of you so I
don't know that we're not gonna do it I
don't know that we will do it why
haven't we done it yet
well one of the things that makes chess
so amazing is not just that it's a
legacy game been around since 600 AD but
it's also a game that was here way or so
obviously the legacy of it and even the
hierarchy of it was here way before
online chess right and when fidei and
the the organizational entities began to
establish official rating systems that
led to titles it actually did an amazing
thing for chess that's you know I know
fidei takes a lot of heat as they should
frankly for some of the things and
decisions that are made but one of the
most important functionalities and
purposes they serve is to is structure
and something that people recognize very
easily and know how good somebody is not
just by their rating but by their title
in fact the term Grandmaster right is
instantly associated with chess and that
then it gets used into other genres like
he's a grandmaster you know what it
means right and when someone says you're
a master chess master
you know instant what that means there's
no like that guy's a fortnight master
that guy's a smash bros this everybody's
like dude I'm pretty good at smash bros
like you want to throw down well I was
better at the n64 like I like the bigger
paddle like did ya the Gamecube suck dry
can we all
and now now I play Smash Bros on the Wii
U or and I love it so but here's the
thing according to all of you you are
the best Smash Bros player in the world
and here's what that's actually led to
I've heard this from all partners at
twitch and a lot of experts in the
eSport industry that has actually led to
utter chaos because when you end up
going to major events people don't
really know who the best are they don't
and they don't know that the person
claiming it isn't as good as they say
they are now streaming has helped some
of that because it's provided motivation
for people who are good at games to then
bring it to the public and get good it
there has been a sort of an unofficial
hierarchy established on Twitch and
gameplay of who the best aren't things
right we can all agree on that but it's
not official right a lot of people think
ninja is the best port 9 player in the
world and then people who know the game
know that he's probably not even in the
top 20 right and and the thing is when
so streaming has helped that the media
and the content has helped but it's
still not in official ranking systems
you don't know who the best chess
players in the world are you know the
best chess players sorry who the best
fortnight players are you know who the
best chess players in the world are you
know the best chess players name is
Magnus Carlsen well you know the actual
best chess movers are it's actually
Leela and stock Fisher you know who the
because their ratings are thirty five
hundred so the point is this right the
point is one of the things that is most
respected and understood about the game
is a very clear ranking and titling
system at chess comm we respect and
honor that feed a systems have earned
that right fides rankings and other
nationally respected and organized
entities have a titling system and so we
acknowledge a candidate master of a
given nation or a national master right
and fidei has its titles and we don't
necessarily have motivation to
undermined it it's despite maybe
people's fears or concerns that feeding
or whatever we have no interest in like
becoming the official dumb of chess
right I mean we love our site there are
a lot of people who play on chess calm
that maybe have never played anywhere
else and that's and that's awesome and
we're thankful and fortunate but we're
not trying to uproot or undermine the
official feed a ranking systems and
anyone can clip that please and send it
to feed a because it's true
please do like so we honor and
acknowledge that rating and titling
system and we don't have interest in
undermining it so to give you very
long-winded answer to the question is
does chess calm have plans for titles
it's a slippery and tricky slope we've
talked about maybe puzzle titles and
other things right but but right now we
just want to have a great experience of
people to play and learn and I'm not
sure that that's necessary for that and
so that's why we haven't done it yet
I think there's cool motivation it would
be cool to have it just like um title
that's why that's why I am and inss
asked right so I get it I'm not trying
to degrade the answer right but that's
why we haven't and it's not as easy as
you would think as far as what the real
purpose of it is and there you go so
hopefully that helps someone send that
you know so I don't know my hold on is
like oh I forgot my producer was here
shout out to our and he's helped me with
this sweet-ass pti looking set up here
go ahead you think you're gonna get away
with saying the Gamecube was a bad
system Wow
are we really bringing up the Gamecube
the most forgotten about game system of
all time besides Sega Genesis no I'm not
a gamer so do you really like GameCube
dude we're gonna we're gonna talk about
okay I'm gonna be educated later about
Nintendo's gaming hierarchy we have the
one now me and my kids what's the one
where you can take it with you
the Wii the Swiss this way leave the
switch right now you know you called a
controller like a paddle the other day I
if I call a a clicker a remote control
channel changer I don't know
I'm a dad or and leave me alone all
right here we go I'm Sam Copeland I know
that guy asked what's your most
anticipated feature on the 2027
featureless Dan oh man what does Eric
put on the 2027 feature list that that I
can even say out loud obviously that's a
joke thank you for that we're doing
everything we can to make everybody
happy all the time it's not that simple
and forgive us so if we're not giving
you your features you want right away at
Justin's says is there a way to make
your online games private so they can't
be used by other players for preparation
so good question
[Music]
currently no but if you saw what I
showed you earlier which is chest out
Club excuse me version of you know
saving analysis and organizing your own
files right I say VHS studies
people use that as well a lot of people
use our analysis I know that people
create repertoires and chess base those
are three very common things the
databases and chef space are great so
let's say those are three versions of it
let me share our screen again and just
remind you this is only gonna be getting
better and better but you know our
analysis tool does allow you to save
anything you want in analysis so let's
see load oops
we'll go here we'll just save a link
that I gave earlier the analysis I did
for a video I did at one time magnus
carlsen wesley so so in my saved
analysis kind of list I have a lot of
things
this is private and you can do anything
you want here maybe you can share it if
you want but you can add any notes to
your games and make them private we have
been a a kind of a proponent of public
information in the sense that we believe
your game archive is public territory so
anyone can see Danny wretches archive
right if we go to my profile and let's
see like we can go to his car whose
profile right anyone can see his cars
games if I want I can see all of
Hikaru's recent games right I can see
that I've actually won 11 times against
the karo and lost 55 times did you know
that or no no I've won ten times okay
good okay I didn't even know that right
so we believe that those who have tried
to lock down chess experiences like a
gun to speak of you know you know all
the direct things we do on this show
it's what the state of chess comm is all
about others that have tried to lock
down PG ends is not necessarily in the
room that we want to operate in public
games are public information and PG ends
our portable game notation and we
believe that and and now what you do
with that game you add your own thoughts
and analysis now you put your own
intellectual property into it right and
that that cannon should only be shared
at your discretion I will say this
people have requested a lot and Justins
e I'll give you the benefited out you're
probably only asking because you're a
serious chess player so we get that if
people have requested privately we have
we have allowed title players to have a
second anonymous account a second secret
account account duplication multi
accounts is not something we allow on
chess comm it is a version of fair play
violation so that is not me telling you
that everyone here
go make a second account it's not within
our rules but obviously we know that
millions of accounts are created every
year here in chest comm some of them are
duplicates and in order to kind of help
the process of title players who do want
to play secretly we have given them
usernames they can keep secret until
they wish to make it public now what
we've done with those accounts to
protect other guys like Hikaru who he's
playing publicly all the time Hikaru
love him or hate him past it has to be
it you know he says he's a star and gets
criticized and and you know people like
and dislike him all the time but his
games are all public you can see his
profile hey Carl doesn't even have a
smurfer anonymous account on chefs comm
unless he's doing a bong cloud speedrun
but even then it's public right the
point is in the interest of protecting
guys like Hikaru if you have an
anonymous titled account we socially
disable that account meaning it's not
allowed to be listed on leaderboards
you're not allowed to compete with
certain things you're certainly not
allowed to compete in cash prizes so we
try to help people like you just in Z to
prepare for tournaments to be a
professional aspiring player by giving
you that opportunity it is a special
exception made for sat at the request I
guess is a very serious you know regular
premium member who wasn't titled also
wanted a second account says hey I'm not
titled yet but I'm 2,000 and I also want
it we might say yes to you - we're not
trying to discriminate against non-title
players but even then it is a process
and people have to ask permission and if
we find people multi accounting there
are there are consequences and so it's
you know we protect the public title
players by limiting those accounts and
we do allow you the opportunity to do it
if you want so that's what I can say
otherwise we believe in the the chesses
public information and once you play a
game it should be known to the community
so that's my that's my statement on that
and my statement now is I am exhausted
we have had a very long show here a lot
of talking for this guy during the state
of chess calm if you appreciate this and
you haven't you've been watching this
full show in a in Avadh later somewhere
please leave a comment let us know you
appreciate it if you appreciate it
please you know in chat let us know that
that you that you uh that you like this
show we're gonna obviously we do it what
four times a year once a quarter and
partly we only do with that often
because it's you know it's something we
you know a lot of energy goes into this
this isn't just commentary but I'm
probably more exhausted now that have
been other shows too discussing very
hard-hitting
hapax so we're gonna take a very quick
break when I come back hopefully you
guys have shared any final questions you
have we're gonna pick a few more final
questions probably the chest TV chat
gets a little bit of favoritism but
we'll check out YouTube and twitch too
so if you have any remaining questions
now's your time otherwise final thoughts
wrapping up today when we return we'll
be back in just a couple minutes